florent cesari professeur d'histoire
contemporaine à l'université d'arras
monsieur césar et bonjour merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france alors
la liste des pays où les états unis
appliquent depuis des années des
sanctions politiques et économiques est
longue est ce que cette loi pourra
vraiment permettre de constater
voilà les
les répercussions sur le terrain sur les
populations justement où cette loi est
appliquée alors il y a deux choses
d'abord les états unis sont
effectivement les champions des
sanctions internationales
mais ils ne sont pas les seuls beaucoup
de au coup d'état ou groupes d'états le
fond l'union européenne le japon la
chine la russie
cela dit cette loi elle passe elle est
passée en à la chambre des représentants
il faut encore qu'elle soit confirmée
par le cdh 1 alors un point intéressant
la chambre des représentants c'est
qu'elle est haché avec une très forte
majorité
donc il ya manifestement des
républicains qui ont voté pour
est ce que ça sera la même chose à la
chambre sénat où les républicains en
tentant la majorité là nous verrons
quant à l'impact je pense que c'est
c'est quelque chose qui aura un effet
psychologique
si si cette loi est votée en effet la
loi demande des études d'impact sur
l'essentiel sur la population des états
sanctionné c'est difficile de faire de
telles études d'impact par exemple pour
les sanctions contre contre l'irak
on va donner 90 on le nombre de morts de
ces sanctions varient selon les études
entre 500 mille et un million cinq cent
dès le suivant les les modes de calcul
suivant contient conflit par des des
conséquences sanitaires à long terme
donc c'est on ne peut pas on ne peut pas
dire que ça des études donneront une
prestation chine de l'effet des
sanctions mais effectivement ça donnera
quand même d une impression générale et
qui ne peut pas bien sûr empêcher
l'application de sanctions si on y tient
effectivement comme instrument politique
mais ça sera un moyen de pression pour
pour les opposants et une fille gabardan
la matière c'est a vraiment un
le pedigree impressionnant si jamais
cette loi est adoptée définitivement
vous l'avez dire par le sénat qui doit
encore valider le texte c'est ce qu'elle
peut également limiter la politique
étrangère américaine
je vois pas trop comment on peut la
limite et parce que les sanctions fonde
un mode de 1mo de d'actions
internationales de d'action qui est le
terme qui remplace le plus en plus la
guerre et dans le cas de trump c'est
très nette si regarde par exemple les
sanctions contre l'iran que c'est un
moyen de faire pression sur l'iran en
faisant souffrir la population 11 ans
s'offrir la de la population en espérant
qu'elle peut aller éventuellement jeu se
révolter contre le régime s'étaient déjà
des choses qu'on voyait si tout cela
sous la guerre froide et je dirais que
c'est difficile à limiter parce qu'en
fait il ya deux moyens maintenant de
contourner la de faire souffrir
l'adversaire politique sans s'engager
soi même il ya un moyen st je dirai qui
et les drones qui effectivement
permettent de cibler tel telle ou telle
personne précisément en limitant au
maximum des effets collatéraux puisque
les les charges sont sont faibles et
puis il ya un moyen fort c'est qu'ils
aient les sanctions ou là on frappe vaut
beaucoup de monde et il ya vraiment une
tendance actuelle à aller dans beaucoup
de pays pas seulement des etats-unis
vers l'emploi de l'emploi de l'emploi
des sanctions merci beaucoup l'auront
cesari d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes professeur
d'histoire contemporaine des états unis